e
what
all right I will call to order the laps
extension
subcommittee uh our our role is to make
sure that the back part of House Bill 25
is exactly correct and to identify money
that can be repurposed that is that is
left over from lapsed lapsed uh line
items uh there's a couple ways I can do
this we can blaze through it or I can go
a little more slow and explain how I do
what I do cuz there are some people who
think that I'm a wizard for knowing how
to do this but my goal would be to have
you all understand how I do
mind I think it would be because some of
us are new some of us aren't as new but
your wisdom is is uh if we can just get
a tenth of your wisdom on what you're
doing I think we would all benefit from
this as we move forward in the future
all right that's what I was hoping for
so let's take a look at House Bill 25
year and if you look in your your brown
sleeve in the LBA orientation that we
had on the very first day there is a
copy of the
2023 House Bill
25 and that starts on its page
18 and that's interesting when we come
to how did I create this sheet that I've
been working
from so hous
25 appropriates anything that is going
to be funded by
bonding the operating budget is things
that are appropriated out
of plain old money now the debt service
for the bonds is paid out of the general
fund or the highway fund or some other
fund but the Appropriations are in House
fill 25 so if we look at the beginning
after the enacting
Clause uh section
one section one is all of the
Appropriations that typically are
General funded but it also includes the
federal
funded which are not bonded because we
just ask the federal government to send
to and then there are like fish and game
has their own fund and the Liquor
Commission has their own fund so if you
were to look at for
example uh the fish and game department
that starts on page two
uh you've got an appropriation for
Hatchery Predator control and then less
other funds so and then the net state is
zero and then there's a footnote that
starts on line 14 that directs the
treasure to issue the bonds uh and The
Debt Service from the fish and game fund
and the same would be true of the liquor
fund yes could you give us a minute to
you well you can look at the previous
Hospital 25 Mr Mr chair May if I can
make a recommendation Mr
Shay this capital budget worksheet that
you put together is is in essence
exactly what he's talking
about that's well right at the moment
I'm talking about the beginning of house
25 that worksheet starts at the laps
extension part okay which is which is
what this committee is Char I'm sort of
explaining how how the first part is put
together well this is Hospital 25 from
this year in in that LBA orientation
document starting on page 18 is Hospital
25 from the previous the previous time
somewhere we have this
year right right if if I might I think
what the chair chairman Jack's trying to
provide to the uh subcommittee is that
how House Bill 25 is structured so it
doesn't matter which one you're looking
at at this moment he just wants to
explain to you what the section one does
and then what the laps extensions do and
then the document that representative
Mills um held up is all the laps
extensions that were in the governor's
int um proposed capital budget and were
uh essentially included in the house
bill 25 is introduced for
2025 great so section one is going to be
the general funded and other funded and
federal
Appropriations and at the beginning it
says the sums are hereby
appropriated now in section in um part
two on starting on page four are the
items now the Constitution says says
that the highway fund can only be be
expended for the construction
maintenance or supervision of
Highways and also because the department
of safety collects the highway fund
they're allowed to charge the expenses
of collecting it to the highway
fund and they call that cost of
collections so if they say they're going
to fund something out of cost of
collections it's
deceptive because
because they're looking at the at the
money before it goes into the highway
fund as opposed to the money being
appropriated after it's already gotten
into the highway
fund so once in a while they're say this
is not this is not affecting the highway
fund because it's appropriated out of
cost of collections but that's just
simply are you inside the door or
outside the door so we wouldn't fall for
that okay so section two is exactly the
same as section one except that their
Highway fund The Debt Service on the
bonds will come from the highway
fund now then you get
into so in section three which starts on
line seven says how we're going to fund
those
Appropriations and it says the treasur
to well section three says that the
agencies are allowed to expand the funds
provided what we want them to do for
example if it says police standards and
training main enterance security
improvements we don't want them to spend
that on air conditioning they're
supposed to spend the appropriation on
the purpose that's in the
bill now sometimes an agency will come
and say we have money left over we want
to use it for this and that happen
several times in the agency
presentations and we'll come to how we
do that
so now in section
four the community colleges and the
university system have their own Board
of Trustees so even though we give them
money it's not quite the same as giving
the Department of Corrections money
because they have their own border of
Trustees that controls the expenditure
of that money so in essence we block
grant them the money hoping that they
will spend it on what it's been
appropriated
for but we don't have as much control
over them because they have their own
Board of Trustees and Mr Shay if you
want to jump in anywhere and and the
community college system and the
university system need the approval of
their Board of Trustees to expend the
appropriation that the um legislature
has provided through the capital budget
so so that's the purpose of sections um
four and five right so section four and
five basically explain
that uh for the community colleges and
University system the board of trustees
is actually who's expending the funds as
opposed to one of the more normal state
agencies
yeah so thank you so when they spoke to
us the other day about specific funding
for specific buildings like they did at
Plymouth and they did at Kean like the
Elliott they're deferring and they're
doing some other work in other locations
so that's their complete choice we just
grant them certain dollar amounts for
funds to do the work that they feel is
responsible so in reality we're not
really responsible for for any kind of
control on that but it could just be
that we we let them know what our
concerns are about not funding things
that we specifically funded for is that
the case so they can still even though
I'm asking them a ton of questions the
other day about specific buildings and
why they're doing that in reality they
have the choice to do that regardless is
that true well for example on line 18
for the community colleges it says for
the completion of the project
enumerated right so they're supposed to
spend the money on the project
enumerated which is whatever building it
is okay so you were going to mention
some thank no I was just going to rep
some Jack said it basically they've
identified the projects that they would
like the legislature to provide funding
for those are the projects they to use
the money for they need to get their um
Board of Trustees to approve the
expenditure of that money after the
appropriation has been provided through
a capital budget so they would be doing
the three uh three campuses the each of
the buildings they identified for each
of those campuses that would be what the
money would be spent on um what they've
asked for this from this committee the
day they presented was to have some
flexibility they would still do those
projects but to move the the money as
they did with um hide Hall they put more
towards that than they did the other
projects because they um determined that
was a better return on value for that
campus at that point but they still want
to do the other
projects Mr chairman so so I I just want
to make sure I understand this right
with the lapse situation so why we're
doing it so in reality um they ask for
the money for specific projects so it's
appropriate for us to review those
projects in detail but when they come
back for instance for laps funding they
may have spent money on a different
scope on the no yeah they're not
supposed to do they would have spent it
on those buildings they identified it
just maybe the timing of when they do
the project for that building so they
have in the case that you just saw
presented to you they had two buildings
that were part of a three Bia
appropriation they front loaded one of
those buildings more than they had
originally proposed and put less towards
the second building but they're still
going to do both projects okay all right
so that that's clear so then I want to
just make sure so with the laps funding
those the the funding that they they've
got in their in their laps extensions
should be directly in line with what
they' done for those specific projects
and that we'd approved correct yeah yes
right except University system didn't
have any lapse extensions community
college did right when we get to okay
when we get down there actually we're
almost there that's section 13 on page
six uh I'll explain why we have lapse
extensions um
so on on page five in section 7 this is
how we're going to fund the
Appropriations and it authorizes the
treasurer to
borrow an amount of money that's equal
to whatever the general fund total is
the highway fund total and the other
funds
total so that's what authorizes the
treasurer to to borrow the
money that's identified in sections one
and then the rest of this down to so the
rest of it is pretty much
boilerplate an important thing is the
section 12 where the division of Public
Works uh supervises the projects and
there's something called the federal
Davis bacon act that says prevailing
wage has to be paid for any federally
funded project and that's so that now
why is it that we have laps extensions
you've you've heard it said one
legislature can't find the
next and so we only appropriate
money for two
years where where's that where statutory
yeah that that's found in the RSA that's
in another statute so in another statute
it says that these these Appropriations
last until the end of that
vium and that's because one legislature
can't B the next now as we know
construction projects last can
potentially last for years and years and
years so in order to prevent losing that
appropriation that's why we have the
lapse extension section
and the first thing it says is the
following appreciations are hereby
extended to June 30th and if you look at
the very
end the effective
date of that
section
year's so the effective date would be
July 1
well the previous the previous one says
that the laps extension section takes
effect on June
30th um doesn't it have to do that for
repurpose so when you're repurposing you
do a hard lapse on things you don't want
to continue forward for June
30 but I'll I'll confirm that after done
here
looking yeah the previous the the uh
2023 version has section 24 which is the
laps extensions shall take effect June
30th and then the remainder shall take
effect July 1st and I think we need that
in this
year's because it catches the lapse
before it lapses
correct so so that's a
mistake yes all right let me just go
through the notes that I
so
so the the items in that laps extension
section are all the Appropriations that
were made in Prior years that we want to
have extended now there's a few things
that can happen one is we extend the
appropriation the agency says yeah we're
not done with the project we need the
money
so that we check that off uh we can find
out that there's an appropriation that
was made in a prior year that isn't in
the new house bill
25 that can mean one of several things
done and the agency agrees that it's
done it's paid all of its bills and it
no longer needs that appropriation
that's sort of the normal way that an
appropriation would expire so then our
question is is there money left in that
line that we can use for something
else and it doesn't count against the
bonding Authority that the treasurer
recommended because it's already been
counted in the previous
here so it's already it's already
authorized but an issued
debt it's already been bonded well it's
already been counted in the amount in
the debt if if you look at the
debt to revenue ratio that they're so
interested in it's already counted in
debt so we can use it again without it
counting against the what the treasurer
recommends yes what the treasurer
recommends is all for the new
Appropriations in section one and two so
I have another question on this so you
mentioned two things there you mentioned
one that if we find that there's
something that hasn't lapsed yet that
there's money left in a project that we
can reallocate that to a different
project we can reallocate it to anything
that we choose to reallocate it to okay
that's something I got to get used to if
you look in and that's one of the
reasons that I referred to the previous
Bill if you look in that middle section
where
the you know that's after that's in
between section one and
two you will find several
examples of
reallocations and
purposes so I just want to be clear on
this we can reallocate it because it's
already been appropriated within our
funding Authority for any project that
is is requested or we can we can we
could allocate to a project that wasn't
requested right okay so then the other
after the governor delivers the pink
book to us yeah that pink book the house
owns the budget until it passes the
budget and sends it to the Senate okay
and we can do whatever we like
so this bill we can amend it in any way
we want
okay no the Constitution sets our salary
so so so then the other question that's
related to that is I just want to make
sure I understand the process again that
if the it's kind of the the the the
sequence of events we typically wouldn't
do anything with funding especially on
lap stuff unless the the particular
Department requested that money is that
not true well they know they're supposed
to know yeah the status of their project
uh whether they've let a contract whe
whether they have funds that they're
paying out on a contract uh and how much
is left in that appropriation they're
supposed to keep track of that uh so
they will know when the project when
they think the project is done they will
know when it's ongoing and if it's done
uh Mr sheay has access to the unexpended
has that's correct and so I don't know
if you have the um 23 House Bill 25 in
front of you by chance I don't think so
no well it's in this that's it's in this
document that was in your brown sleeve
to begin with so so repent Brown just to
kind of sum up what's happening is today
what you're doing in this subcommittee
is you're looking at the laps extensions
in the back of um the capital budget the
agencies have been presenting to this
Committee in full um what the status is
of their their projects and if they need
a lapse extension or not in some
instances they might have provided a
value of what they didn't
expend I will check that against the
statement of Appropriations to see if
that number matches up um and if it does
that amount becomes available to reuse
for another project that may has been
requested as in front of the full
committee so in Prior Capital budgets we
we call it
repurposing and you'll have this
committee will make a decision on we
want to fund a project a in the
Department of Transportation in the
repurposing section we would take the
money left over from projects that were
done and use it for a new appropriation
for that department usually it's for a
project that they presented to the full
committee and that you've discussed and
come to some agreement on and all the
agreement is done on the full committee
basis it's not done by this subcommittee
so representative R if if you're looking
for for a timeline of this all the
presentations that we just heard today
I'm this this past week those
are for this this current budget and
this current bonding when we get to the
end of everything when we look at the
lapse extensions these are for previous
ones from years past that they still
haven't spent all that money yet it's
taken that that long and so we have to
keep track of all the money that's still
out there when they finally do finish it
as as representative Jack said when when
the project is finally finished and
we've given them $100 for their project
and they've six years later they come to
us and go the project is done we only
spent 95 we got $5 over one of two
things will happen they'll either say
well we've we've got this other project
you gave us 104 we're going to spend
we're going to overspend by about $5
we'd like to repurpose this money for
that project or the other thing is that
we're good we've got nothing else to do
it on we're we're lapsing that money
it's back it's back to the committee
that's when the committee takes that
money and turns around and looks at
where we're currently at on hb25 the
current everybody is Christmas wish list
and we we add up all those little $5 and
$12 and $16 here and if we're I think
we're getting close back to
$649,000 that we will be able to we can
either repurpose at all and I don't
think it's ever been done but we can
turn it back into the we can turn it
back into the general fund if we wanted
to can we not it it would just be a
lapse so basically just clean the books
off so it doesn't help that way you just
answered one of the questions whether we
return that back or whether we use that
funding you know when we look at the
governor's budget whether we say we
agree with all of this or
not we may or may not agree with it as
absolutely okay right so I I'm good with
that now I just want to make sure I
understood the sequence and the
authority we had as far as spending that
money or repurposing that money because
I'm not used to that as from my business
background so thank you one thing that
always happens is agencies will come in
and say the governor didn't fund this
but we think it's really important and
so that's sort of the menu of items that
we pick and choose when we have extra
money as to what to fund and not
fund um so the one last thing I want to
cover is so if we look at where it says
the appropriation made to Department of
administrative services in and then
there's the scoby cook and I want to
cover how to read
that uh so it says the appropriation
made Department administra Services in
113 colon 1 Roman 1 A1 for Courthouse
generators now if I go back to my 20123
house bill
25 uh it turns out so every time a bill
passes it gets through how a bill
becomes a law to the end it gets the it
gets assigned a chapter number so if I
went over to the State library and
pulled down the laws of
1967 there would be chapter one chapter
2 chapter 3 those are all the bills that
passed in
1967 and so
uh the H Bill 25 in 2023 is chapter 113
so if I went to the laws of 2023 it
would be chapter 113 would be the text
of this bill so the 2023 so
113 is the chapter number of laws of
2023 colon one is section one so that's
that's our section one that is the
general fund Capital
Appropriations and then a and then one
is the depart Roman one is the
Department of administative Services a
is Court facilities and number one is
Courthouse
generators so that whole expression
refers to that
appropriation and if you had the 2023
Hospital 25 in front of you you could
follow along and find that and then the
courthouse and then later on so now if
you get to if you go down below to
number nine you'll see that that was
made in 2021 chapter
107 extended by so now if you went to
the lapse extensions of 2023 you would
see section 24 is the laps extensions
number two and then it gives the purpose
again so that's how to read all these
Goble
references that's good that's good but I
guess my question is what do we actually
check on this do we actually go through
each of these Lin well we're going to do
that in a minute um so now if I go back
to I'm I'm going to I'm going to go
slightly out of my one of our purposes
is to identify money that we can use for
something else so I'm going to go
slightly out on my lane and mention that
during the agency presentation in
section one we determined that the
Jeffrey ringe CTE renovation did not so
we do not put an appropriation for a CTE
in on there's a local match required for
a for a for a
CTE and we learned on Tuesday that
Jeffrey and ringe did not
pass uh the bonding Authority that they
would need to supply their local match
for this appropriation
so and also Milford did not that's an
mail that Mr Shay sent out
yesterday and so the normal practice of
the committee would be to remove
that there is no CTE waiting in the
wings shovel
ready to take its place so that is $18.5
million that we will delete from the
governor's recommended budget because of
the failure of the town to appropriate
their
reuse
well that's the only one I mentioned so
far mil oh well there was a Milford
Milford was the backup is is a is the
next school there's a rotation of CES
and Milford is the next one in line and
they're not ready either so there is no
school that is ready that could take the
place of this one so just to be clear
Milford is not listed milford's not here
it used to be it used to be that we
tried to do two per budget and they're
getting so expensive that that kind of
fills up the budget represent Jack if I
could just interject I think that we
want to refocus this subcommittee on
just the lapse extensions because you
haven't had public hearing have two more
comments on section one and then I'll
then then we'll do that okay so excuse
me just for education purposes me so
that money was originally set aside for
education for the CTE and again is that
$18 million is it similar to what we'd
spoken about before that we can
repurpose that money for anything or do
we do it within it's not appropriated
yet okay so we could use it to reduce
the amount that we're going to
appropriate right uh which we've
discussed the fact that the governor had
143 million and the treasurer
recommended somewhat less
so one thing that we might choose to do
is reduce the total amount that we're
bonding general fund bonding and we now
we have $18
million right off table uh at the top of
page two there was a typo on line to uh
the word replacement should be deleted
and at the end 51 should be
50 and and you had that I would
assume the Winn pasak River basin
control fund right but th those are
things that we would discuss at the full
committee not at this last exension and
then the judicial branch uh deleted
their so now we'll go to the laps
extensions now let me explain
so Mr Shay's worksheet only considers
the lapse extension section in the
current House Bill
25 the worksheet that I sent to you
before we started and I think Mr Shay
distributed you should have a copy of
both worksheets so mine looks like this
and as represent Jack has indicated this
is the capital projects that were in the
back of the governor's int uh proposed
capital budget that want to be extended
and were subsequently included in House
Bill 25 as introduced represent Jack's
document which he's holding up is just a
listing he took the laps extensions in
the capital budget for 2023 and he
compared that to what was in um 2025
right so the way I produce this is I go
to the
2023 as as
enacted and I make a line for every
appropriation or extension in the 2023
version which and it's a lot easier if
you have the one from the budget
previous to that because the extensions
tend to be the same from year to year so
you'll notice
in my in my document that I've got the
2023 Appropriations and then 2021 those
were extensions that were in that budget
and this this means and then you apply
the numbers from this year's hosal 25
that's what's in the column to the right
so the first one is from 20 is the one I
just read out from uh for for Courthouse
generators that was that was the very
first appropriation in
2023 and it's been extended by number
one in this year's laps
extensions and so on now when
administrative Services was
here
uh the the the reason why that's helpful
is if you find one that's not
extended uh like for
example the Hillsboro County South
Cooling and controls is not mentioned in
this year and that's that's a case where
either the project is done or it's been
accidentally
omitted and if it's accidentally omitted
we want to add it back so that they
don't lose their
appropriation now we had one we have one
case this year where the agency has
asked for an a lapsed value to be added
back and that's that's uh the former
Chairman's in under
the the Department of
Transportation it's number it's between
it would fall between 183 and
184 and the caption is Caroline stra
straford Freight rail improvements and
it would be 2023 Roman 15 number
three you I'm on well I don't have page
numbers on mine it's Department of
Transportation General funds it's the
last page it would be between 183 and
so the agency has requested that we add
that
extension so that that those funds don't
lapse and they can continue to spend
them because without adding it back at
the end of the at the end of the fiscal
year in June that appropriation would
lapse if we don't do anything and they
wouldn't be able to further expend the
appropriation for Caroline straford
Freight rail improvements that was made
in
23 yeah so I thought you said that this
had lapsed but it hasn't lapsed yet it
will lapse on June 30th so they didn't
unless it's mentioned in the laps
extension section of of this year's
House Bill 25 once once the line has
lapsed it's done right well okay that's
un mention you you kind of there is a
loophole okay and that is if the agency
has encumbered the funds and you
probably know from the town what that is
you've signed a contract that obligates
you to pay the funds then they won't
lapse even if they're not
mentioned but it does preclude you from
contract did you want to add anything to
that yeah yeah so some agencies do it
that way they just they don't they don't
laps extend their Appropriations and
method of having it not
lapse we typically would make sure that
was included
well we can I mean we would sort of
defer to how the agency wanted to do it
I personally recommend that it be
included because you never know when
something might come up and you might
need to sign a contract with a
plumber you know to do some to do a
little bit of additional work or
something like that in order get the
project
done but that's just that's just my
personal
view
so I think so let's so do do you want to
go through um my document to start with
and I can just explain to the members
how I've structured
it uh sure if you want to do that so if
if you look at this document the long
sheet I think it's
18 pages long so it's all the laps
extensions like I said that were
proposed in the governor's capital
budget if it says okay in the column to
the right that means the agency
confirmed that that laps extension is
correct and still needed yeah there's
24 if there's a question or um something
that needs to happen with that lapse
extension it'll be grayed out so if you
go to page
four U laps extension
um 49 I have that they don't need that
anymore so that they can um that will be
removed from this
list and if there's any bounces
remaining that would be repurposed I
have that there was
81,000 and that's not
$1,500 that was going to be repurposed
okay so that line has
81500 that we can use again so that's
that's one of our findings is that line
49 can be deleted and has $81,500
that we can use
again and that's it for the Department
of administrative services that I has
correct another question on that is
there a reason why we just put okay on
here and when we grade these out we
don't put the the dollar amount that's
we're considering laps so that we could
use this I have a separate sheet with
all that
okay see that here with that so that I
know as we're looking at it we can have
an idea what we're doing I have it all
right here for you okay thanks yeah and
I'll I'll give that to you now I didn't
want to leave it on the table because it
I wanted to have an explanation for it
right because looking at it you might
not have understood what it was but
thanks okay so we've done our first
important piece of work we've we've
found money that can be lapsed that that
can be repurposed we found an item that
should be deleted and it has money in it
for so the next agency is agriculture
markets and food they responded by mail
they have one
appropriation that's from 21 and they
want to keep
it so for the agencies that responded
through an email you'll have a
three-page staple together document
it'll be handwritten the agency's name
and a highlight on it and that's just
their saying their comments to you
saying that yeah we need this laps
why so our next agency is Community
College
right I'm on my second page under
food and Jack which document are you
walking through
well I I I use my document because it
allows me to locate the items that are
lapsing I I would suggest to the members
that you use my document
well yeah because it it does show you
where there's things that are shaded out
and yeah maybe the difference rep of
Jack has notes on his document that's
why he's holding on to his right but I I
think it would be harder to go back and
forth between his document and this
document so just just an additional
point it's kind of interesting we get
about six different documents we shiting
back and forth from I'm looking at your
budget extension worksheet then you give
us this sheet here I don't know why it
could be Consolidated onto one sheet
which gave the dollar amounts and the
lapse extension information too just I
don't know why we go back and forth
through multiple documents it's it was a
timing thing with the documents I
finalized the one in your right hand
yesterday afternoon okay I had already
done this one I was still asking
agencies questions sometimes this
meeting occurs before we have all the
final information so we just identify
yet there's something coming I'm still
working with the agent gency okay I'll
just transfer these numbers to the sheet
thank you great I think I mean in the
end you don't really need to because
it's the document in your right hand is
the one that you're going to really be
more concerned about all right thank
you I have two lapses for the Community
College do we know one of them is for
2021 colon 14 critical maintenance one
is for the NCC engineering technology
you know if there's any money in
so unless it shows up on this sheet even
if the agency said they were done with
it and it was completed um there was no
money left unless it showed up on this
sheet that makes it
easy okay our next agency is Corrections
and we
have the the agency got back to us with
wanting with uh some items that were in
house bu in the governor's version that
335 okay so item 64 we we want to delete
because that project is complete and it
has
$335,000 of usable
money which is a nice find
uh number 65 they want to lapse and that
has
zero and then 66 they want to lapse that
yep and then
67 they want to
lapse uh 64 65 and 66 were all that they
wanted to lapse oh so 67 they do not
okay and there's quite a number that are
not in hospital
have let's see so there's perimeter
2019 that would assume doesn't have any
money in it
and
then that's for from
2019 so
85,86 the one you're looking at is
19 so if you look on this single page oh
oh okay yeah good so what what happens
with some agencies is they know the
Project's not going going to need the
labs extension but there is some bounce
left that's what is
reflected on the one pager in some
instances the lapse extension was
included in the proposed bill that's
what we're cleaning up they don't need
it so we're going to take it out in one
instance we have a case where the agency
said oops we really want that laps
extension let's add it back in which was
the Department of Transportation uh rail
okay so there's an item that you
wouldn't find in housefield 25 because
it lapsed and there's
remaining in my on my document it's
72 yeah I know it's on the
right so we'll be able to use
that and there's replace electrical
services which has 267 we wouldn't
bother with I would assume because I've
added that one in to try to get to the
um the final number is 6495 and then
8308 yeah from 17
yep and just for completeness
that dra
from yeah so you have
um you have the trades building for
335,000 it's a 2021 project you have the
roof replacement for the nnh hcf which
is a for
21387 which is a 2021 capital
appropriation you have the door
controller upgrade for the Department of
Corrections for 31,1 141 which is also a
um 2021 appropriation and the last 2021
appropriation was the replacement of the
6,183 the next correction projects come
from the 2019 capital budget that was
they replace electrical services for
267 and then the last two projects from
Corrections are from the 2017 capital
budget for the body alarms of
43534 and then the transitional work
center um bathroom replacements for
$838 so that that accounts for all the
uh lapses that would come from the
Corrections so does everyone understand
how this is working good yes okay and
that that was a pretty fertile Agency
for getting money back if if I can just
interject for for the new members in the
past this committee met like this and it
was separate it was just like when we
went through all the agencies coming in
and and they they would then present our
laps extensions that's that's how
representative Jack developed his own
little system here on doing this because
you had to refer you had to have all the
sheets to refer to it and everything
else and we wouldn't know any of these
numbers until the end of today and we'd
sit there and go through all and it
would be an all day thing uh Mr Shay
came up with the genius idea when we
started to schedule all this that said
let's bring them in and get the laps
extensions at the same time they make
the regular presentation so he has done
all this background work that this
committee used to have to do and shorten
it up into uh these these documents so
you you've got the full explanation from
representative Jack on of how this whole
thing works and we'll thank Mr Shay for
for the shortcuts on all this stuff
because otherwise we would be here till
good 4:30 5 o'clock so now it's easier
to just skim through all this and double
our next agency is
education and we have money
in uh right before
73 uh pre-engineering technology has
continuing our next agency is energy and
they have two that are continuing they
Services
$3,274 and that's one that we should be
3274 and everything else in
Environmental Services was
up and then fishing game has three items
and then Health and Human Services we
had to send them back with
homework to go through these and which
respond question yeah thank you Mr
chairman why is on your sheet CR why is
one 10 shaded but it says
okay it should have said completed
that's my error okay so it should be
it's completed it's going to be deleted
okay perfect thank you and also with um
Health and Human Services if you turn to
114 and 116 those are shaded and marked
as
completed Health and Human Services got
back to me um later yesterday after I
produced these documents and said that
they made an error and that they would
like lapse extensions to continue for
those two projects okay so which one of
those again uh 114 and 116 thank you so
those are going to be kept not
deleted and and
115 should
lapse that's correct okay 110 111 112
and 115 should be deleted from the um
lapse extension
list and it looks
like the only one
that has
money it doesn't say that was going to
be question 112 and 115 waiting on a
final invoice do we have any idea if
that's going to be flat or they'll be uh
there's no they don't plan on have
anything left over in those accounts the
um $1,800 was the um 2021 beas systems
modernization that's number 110 in the
bill but we're going to delete that so
in in HHS we're deleting 110
112 we're keeping 114 at their request
we're yeah you no we're
keeping sorry I apologize go ahead is
that right yep you're right we're
keeping 114 we're deleting 115 and we're
keeping 116 at their request and then uh
the only one that has money of any of
so are
we are we all correct on on that
do
and what I have is that they wanted to
lapse 124
that's correct and there's no balance to
that with zero and everything else was
correct there on on the one pager sheet
there was a project that they um they
were lapsing from 2019 related to cyber
oh so that
so that's
5256 on my sheet that's between 122 and
so so represent Brown that's another
reason why it doesn't all show up on
there all right so the courts had three
projects uh there were 125 126 and 127
and Hospital
25 and they got back to us by mail and
they say they would like to
money is that right that's correct and
then the money in 120 they're going to
they provided text for us that where
they would repurpose 125 and
127 within their own Department This Is
Not Unusual when an agency has money
left over that they want to keep it and
they will propose a project within their
own Department
to repurpose it to so I had forwarded to
the committee the email from the courts
related to these three projects um the
two projects that they want to extend
are
ecort and they would like to change the
title of the project from ecourt to
ecourt
and Associated critical infrastructure
so the ecort was a very um narrowly
focused project as they've um gotten
into it understood that there's other
electronics or Communications that need
to be updated so that they can continue
to process these files that they use
through the ecourt system um so they
were hoping the committee would consider
that um when you meet next week or the
week after when you start to make final
decisions it doesn't have to happen but
it is a request of the judicial branch
and um they'd be willing to come meet
with the committee um next week or
whenever the chair would like if if they
would like that at all do we have a
dollar chair
AI sure do we have a dollar value
assigned to 125 and
127 that is
uh so we can make that
decision yeah um so it's $1.3 million
just over that is that between the two
the two yeah so it's 1.3 million 1
3 and I misspoke when I said they didn't
have money in Project 126 it's actually
on the one pager at the top of the line
they had
okay okay
635 6035
on
126 so on on my document those two
projects are grayed out not because they
the laps extension will go away but
there's been a request related to that
specific laps uh extension so if the
committee were to um agree to the
request I would have to go into the laps
extension and change the title so this
laps extension would go from ecort to
the new name to whatever the new name
becomes if it is the um what they
recommend or ask for which is the um
Associated critical INF and Associated
critical infrastructure then that would
be amending this lapse extension title
to reflect that if I'm not mistaken we
have to actually go back to the 2021
house B 25 and amend the appropriation
so and then extend it yeah with the
title so what I've spoken to the chair
about is um putting together the
requests that these agencies are making
in this manner and providing that to the
committee if the committee wants to see
it next week or the week after whenever
you have your work sessions um so that
you can see exactly what would be
changing but when an agency requests to
change a title of a project that had
been appropriated in a previous capital
budget we actually amend the previous
capital budget to reflect that title and
then you have to amend the lapse
extension to have the new title and in
the current capital budget you'd have a
section that does all that and and you
would also say as amended by this act
yes yep
yep or we can choose to take to
1.3 million and repurpose it to another
project I would um before the I would
suggest that you would talk to the
judicial branch and have them come in to
explain there is still some ecort
specific functions that they're doing
but there's some other pieces to the
outside of that and I think in the email
I sent they gave you some examples some
explanation of it right and and they
Associated some cost with some of the
things that they are currently doing
related to ecort and some of the
expanded things that they would like to
do but it's not um everything yet um
it's one of those situations was as they
move further in this project they've
been doing ecort since 2012 I think is
when they got the first appropriation so
this has been a very um long standing
project trying to get all the courts
connected trying to get all the ability
to move information back and forth
fluidly between the courts the people
who use the courts um and as Things
become new and as new things are created
and old Things become obsolete they have
come up with some new challenges so they
were just seeing if there was a
possibility to to extend the title so
the I say all that it's a long-winded
explanation to say there probably isn't
$1.3
million they still need some of that to
do the ecourt and if they're still do in
the ecourt we wouldn't lapse it but you
wouldn't change the title so they would
be very narrowly focused
still right yeah this also
is they so that people can
electronically file cases instead of
having to file them on paper at a
courthouse so so if I might I just I
just want to make sure I understand so
this is typical that since this is all
related the ecort and the associated
infrastructure to support the ecort this
would be typical so will they give us
some type of summary on that so that we
understand we can make so we can make
the
connection somewhere I'm not looking for
any
paperwork
okay
oh
thank you knew this was G to come well I
suspected but I made plenty of copies
for everybody here as well as the
yeah we we talked about this ahead of we
talked about this ahead of time normally
this would be something also brought up
in the committee because we we Public
Works and highways we are the oversight
to all this so we don't let them do
whatever they want if they've got a
change and it's justifiable
we we're the check in balance and we
but again it's not a decision for here
it's just to let you know why that was
grayed out and that the request was made
this is something that the full
committee would full committee will
discuss will discuss after the public
here is for the fact finding to go so
far as to say they want to repurpose on
these lines and then we report that back
to the full committee
correct our next agency is liquor and
everything was good but it's liquor
funds
so uh there it doesn't help us with any
general fund item right and I I put out
a long sheet it looks like a
spreadsheet that was their response back
to
me yep and to repm Jack's point because
it is using liquor
funds whether they have money to lapse
or not it doesn't help the committee
with repurposing unless there was a
liquor project requested there was not
Affairs oh sorry so can you explain that
it just goes away to me what you
mean funding is just basically gone it's
gone it just lapses back to the the
liquor fund so if there's it's it's all
it doesn't get you reused for anything
it doesn't stay on the books it gets
cleaned up and and zeroed out so that's
it's not carried going forward in the
state financials thanks
in military
Affairs everything was good uh they did
send later uh items 138 139 and 143 they
slightly that's that's another case of
where the agency's requesting to change
the title of the
projects um they indicated to you the
committee when they were before the full
committee that um in trying to get some
of the federal funds they needed to
change the
uh project Focus to make them more
competitive with the process that's used
to get those funds um the three the
three projects two of them are full 100%
Federal fund one of them it's a $4
million project of which a million
dollars is General funds um to match
it's a 7525 match and um so that was
their request it's it relates to the
Pembrook um site to to expand some of
the
uses and again I have a I'll have a an
example of an amendment to provide to
the committee if it's something that the
committee as a full is interested in
looking
at so can you explain this to me so it
says request to repurpose would need to
update laps extension language what is
right so what I explained earlier if the
committee were to agree to the title
change I would need to make sure that
that laps extension title changed along
with it just language on well well we
also have to go back to the original
appropriation and change that title
right and then it can and then it can
lapse
forward yep yeah if you look in the 2023
there's a couple of examples of doing
that I think if when we finish up with
the laps extensions themselves I'm
happily sit for a few minutes with
anybody that wants to talk some
more no no just I think this is not slow
at all this takes a long time to get
used to so you're everyone here is a
quick study
um it's probably worth uh there's a
couple of land items here it's probably
worth mentioning the reason we hold
those it's kind of a reserve fund to buy
land the reason why is any uh military
construction has to be on state land and
sometimes the the dod will come and say
we have this project we want to do in
some town triester but and so we want
you to buy this land so they have to
have the money
so that's why they keep in reserve these
item these land items so that if they
get a we don't have to wait the full two
in
2017 and just a point I'd like to make
typically when we're trying to come up
with these uh values for repurposing I
don't look for things less than
$1,000 except when we're I'm trying to
get to a number in this case we we were
at 649 just over 649 so I grabbed a
couple of um
um smaller projects to bump it as high
could but I didn't grab the one and2
projects that were out there so all
right so everything on dncr matched
$382 so unless anyone has a question on
that uh the
PDA actually came to us and they had uh
three Appropriations for the Turning
oops and then police standards and
training came to
theirs interestingly we have we have a
repurpose in a 2024 bill hb10
210 uh you skipped over
safety uh well I put it in alphabetical
oh so that was it that's at 208 209 and
210 and they want to keep those three
laps they want keep so it's interesting
to note that in 2024 House Bill
1043 repurposed the
210 yeah uh they had come in with a bill
before this committee right yep that
doesn't happen very often but if you're
ever
curious that's the
reference and then Revenue
administration at line
171 uh they sent us mail that they want
to keep that this is the system that
collects all the taxes one of which we
anymore that that's correct it's the uh
what they call the rims system or rims
so uh couple Capital budgets ago they
con proposed to A legislature that their
old tax system was Obsolete and out of
date and they needed a newer system to
um for security purpose one because
there was some issues with the sharing
of the federal um IRS information that
there were having some challenges with
that because of security related to the
old system and the um ease of tax pay
taxpayers filing so they wanted to get
more e files available many taxpayers
prefer to do that than filling out a
piece of paper and sending it in um so
that Rim system is allowed them to do
that the unique thing about the rim
system is that I was just mention this
it was um bonded with some general funds
directly and then um there's a special
account that was created
that is from the uptake and the uptake
is defined as Revenue that we would not
have otherwise
collected because of the rim system as a
result of the rim system we are now
collecting it and and one of the very
simple um results was that the notices
to taxpayer that you haven't paid your
bill that used to not happen before this
system now it happens and they get
collect Revenue as a result of that
there's a it's all in Statute in in
terms of how much money can go into that
system it's meant to just pay the bond
for the the excuse me into that account
it's meant to pay the bond for this
system and when that's done all the
money would go back to the general
fund so but anyways it just it was a a
creative way of an agency trying to find
a for a fairly expensive system a way to
pay for that without taking most of your
uh uh banial appropriation that you see
for the capital budget right that was an
extremely expensive project and that was
really the only way that we could could
squeeze it in is that it's kind of
yes all
now
Ben yeah the next agency I have is
safety General so I mentioned earlier
that because like for example because
of because of the supervision of
highways things sometimes we apportion
things uh between general fund and
Highway
are um I have that they wanted to lapse
178 and
179 that's correct and both of those
there's no money associated with those
to add to the sheet um both of those
were funded with um dedicated funds
the fire truck and HVAC was from there's
a fire emergency account that um they
used to pay for that and then the
criminal records has a dedicated fund
that was used to pay for that system so
any amounts left would just lapse back
and not come from those those uh so
we're gonna so we're going to in this
agency we're going to delete 178 and
179 and then in the highway
they have stayed here but they didn't
have any appropriation that was active
the last thing we did for them was build
building so in transportation
General we are going to add an extension
between well it would fall between 183
and
184 uh it's 2023 Roman 15 number three
Carol and straford Freight rail
improvements uh requested
by
uh the gentleman in the back well I I
think that um the department agreed that
right to extend that laps extension
after discussions with the um the vendor
that they were going to work with with
that
project the project had been
um encumbered and and had gone to get a
contract it's not due to be completed
until December of upcoming December 25
um so the thought was just to keep the
laps extension in there in case there
was any other issues with this um
done and
then uh in 206 and
207 uh when they were here they these
are very old there bit there another one
of these cases where we might need the
money because of a statutory reason
uh but they wanted to repurpose that
those those Appropriations are from 2005
and
1999 right and I forwarded an email got
the language on that to a committee
where they uh to the committee where
they want to repurpose those two
accounts um which is about there's about
$825,000 available in the two accounts
and repurpose it for Rail and um ties
for the state-owned active lines
so this is something where that um they
have come in and asked for
Appropriations related to that in the
past and the department doesn't believe
they'd be able to use the funds in the
manner that they were originally
designated for and they are making this
um
request so this would be an example of
um you would zero this out and and do a
new appropriation you would repurpose
this because it would be for a slightly
different purpose overall right and so
190 is an example of where we've made an
appropriation for this in the past may I
sure so for those two items to
repurpose they currently have requests
in for rails and ties so can we move the
money from these two that is left over
to help fund the new request of rails
and ties is that what so when the
committee meets full committee you would
discuss that option you could decide how
you would want to handle that um you
could provide the agency with the
request that they have here and not
provide the other request that was made
related to rails and ties for the state
owned but you wouldn't let me reframe my
question then okay so they want to use
this money as a repurpose and then under
the new re request it would be added on
to this repurpose money so it would be
adding the two together no it's going to
be two separate Appropriations there's a
request for new appropriation that
they're asking for the rails and ties
that they presented to you on uh Tuesday
this
week a second request is to repurpose
this uh these two projects to be used
for rails and ties on the state owned
lines as
well it's not adding the two together
they would be separated separate but the
for the for the same types of purposes
it maybe um to give them the ability to
uh whereas they identified there's like
four miles a track that they really need
to fix in the Conway Scenic area I think
this would be more of
a um yes like a Statewide so as they
identify places of their state own track
that they really need to fix they can
come and do that without asking in two
years could we please have some more
money to do it but it is up to the
committee as a full to decide how you
want to if you want to even do this and
how that would relate to the project
that they've asked for going forward in
the 25 budget that's actually the
purpose of the subcommittee to to make
these decisions and recommendations and
get all the wise the wherefores and
everything else like you're doing so
that when we come
Tuesday normally the chair doesn't sit
in so you present it to me and say this
this is what they want want to do this
is we looked into it we did ask the
questions this is what we recommend and
then I'll put it to our entire committee
to
say what do we want to do well what what
we would normally do is say we located
an item that the agency wants to change
and
then I will still make the report even
even though you're
here it doesn't happen that often that
they're repurposing it for the same that
they ask for in
current all foret right what we're
looking at with hp2 is that current
requests what this committee is looking
at is just mopping up and taking care of
all the pass and the money that's
already been allocated so it's and and
the
new and the repurpose appropriation
would be 2025 colon some other section
number where this is lapsed in the new
is is appropriated so you can see an
example of that in last year if I might
along the same lines as was talking
about do you know if the the governor
had appropriate had plans for money I
don't recall from the testimony whether
she had money in her budget for rails
and ties no no they she did not okay so
so this would basically offset what
they're looking for since it's already
non included in the budget no it will
not offset it what if I understood
correctly they want to take the money
for the repurpose that's going to be
over here that's be I understand and
they want to appropriate more money
that's for the for the the same thing
yeah so that's going to be a money and
then they got B money
and yeah I that's what I was trying to
get CL that that's the request they have
a bucket and a B bucket but it'll be up
to the full committee to decide how they
want to handle the two buckets and it
could become a single bucket and there
could be a SE bucket or no bucket
no yes small but again that's not for
today's right right so Transportation
highway there wasn't any change to what
was in there and then um Veterans Home
change and that no that
so does does everyone think they could
year
so so just in recap on your single sheet
then after looking at all the projects
that the agencies believe that they will
be completed by the June 30
2025 there is approximately
$649,500
that could be considered for projects
that are being requested by the agencies
here and that again would be a
discussion for the full committee after
the uh chair Jack presents this
committee subcommittee's results you
know that he would he would present that
we went through this that there's a
lapse extension requested for the
straford Carol line that's not included
and that after reviewing all the laps
extensions that aren't needed there's a
value that can be um considered by the
full committee to for projects that have
been
requested it does not mean you have to
use it it just means it's available to
consider doing
that so so representative Boger with
okay the
request for the rail from do that has
governor and
they have the dot has also repurposed
that this
$649,000 is money available that should
we want to fund their a bucket which is
their request we can do that with this
money there you go that's just what I
wanted to as long as we were having a
bucks and C buckets and bck buckets
there and and we also have the the two
line items that we
identified that the where the where the
agency has withdrawn the request so
that's
um I noticed on the bottom of your very
very useful
page I love it and thank you very much
this this has been a tremendous help
this one pager uh but there's a three
lines at the bottom of it right would
you expand upon those three and thank
you for bringing I meant to do that
earlier oh yeah good idea so when the
agencies presented um the laps extension
information to you when they presented
their Capital budgets these three
projects showed up with um potential
money
available these projects were never
extended with a lapse extension they
were encumbered projects so the money is
truly not available for us to repurpose
at this time because technically when
the project ended anything left should
have gone to zero they didn't have this
this extension that I could go and go
into the law and say oh move this
extension and and we'll take the money
from it so I just wanted to note that in
case somebody remembered when the
corrections came in there were these two
projects that on their list why didn't I
include it in the above number so if I
may um where does the little
over 20,000 I think it looks like it's a
little over 20 grand yeah where does
that go just gets taken off the books
yes so if I might go back to something
that represent bogert uh kind of alluded
to I think so this 649,000 that is
coming back through the uh laps
issue this money can be used for any
line item that has been requested by any
Department it's not specific to we took
away 335,000 from one Department this is
for general fund to help offset the cost
in any area that we feel is the most
appropriate that we would recommend
thank
you and for instance because you got a
yeah I was going to sh I was going to
share this with the full committee on
Tuesday and I've got so much paperwork
here I I don't I don't know what I did
with
but when you looking for Mr sh how many
additional requests what what was our
additional requests our
original Governor's budget was
$143
Million our additional requests were
$102 million for additional
requests so you can tell that that that
that if we funded everybody with
everything we' we'd
Yeah well yeah so so we
had yeah this this is the one yeah this
we had total new requests of $102
million above what is already in our
$143 million Governor's
budget so that's what we're going to be
looking at
on
Tuesday out of that 102 million
102 m900
th000 we've got we' got 600,000 to th
toward
that and if I may we have a
a if it's an appropriate
ask uh do we have a goal in mind of uh
we'll discuss that on
Tuesday our
goal so Mr chairman representative Boger
starting to read my mind so you
mentioned earlier right that this a
Governor's budget there's the requested
amounts and then there's the treasury
secretary's amount that's what we're
going to be talking about eventually is
you just a question for anybody
on this sheet here the additional
requests there was something public
radio the Press whatever that when the
budget was being worked on that the
governor had put out I want
your needs but not your wants is this
needs items or
wants would you have an opinion many of
those would be what the agencies
presented at the governor's Capital but
hearings last June yes that didn't get
included in this document so they many
of the agencies presented to you in the
priority number that they had because
some of the things identified in here by
the governor weren't at the same
priority level as the agency so um I I
wouldn't I don't know if it's a need or
a want but it was what was presented in
um the agencies feel it was appropriate
to bring it back to your attention right
representative Newton this this is your
this is your child's Christmas
list it's the governor has is is your
budget that you can afford for your
child's Christmas list it's fair to say
that every
time the agencies come in with items or
a different priority
order uh some of them were funded in the
governor's budget some not but they feel
it's every time this happens they come
in with their own list of things they
would like to see funded that they feel
are
I if I go to the uh uh compare
report okay um on there it says the
total appropriation sections one and two
is
million
782 does that 207 million
actually I guess the
207 is uh a subset of the the 143 to 4
million from the highway fund bonds and
total other funds and all that is
subtracted from it and then what we're
looking at at the 143 approximate level
is what the governor said should be
bonded the the 143 is the general
funds and that's what we would bond is
the 14 no you'd be bonding the other
stuff as well but it's not being paid by
the um general fund that portion so the
highway fund would pay its portion the
other funded agencies would pay its for
portion so we would be looking at trying
to attempt to bond 207
sheet right the thing we so it's 170
million I think there's some federal
funds included on that one sheet yes
bonded okay so we would subtract out the
toal 170 million yeah the 37 38 million
would get subtracted out I'm going to
round numbers because we're just talking
generally talking so we would subtract
out of the 200
7 uh the
37 and then that's what would be looked
at as state bonding even though the
funds to pay for the bonds would come
from separate
locations that's correct and then if we
207 and add the
New U additional
requests that would take that up to over
[Music]
300 if you included everything yes but I
believe when the treasurer was here she
talked
about the are talking about I'm just
looking at the ask y the ask is the
total ask is
over 309 thou 309 million well on the
bright side that's less than a billion
which was the ask for the governor when
the governor's capital budget hearing
back in June well to be fair we ask the
agencies to come in with whatever they
might want and then the Press reports
they Big Spenders they want a billion
dollars but that's what we asked them to
do and then prioritize from there as to
representative boger's point the number
that we manage to is the general fund
bonding Vis what the treasurer
recommended and then the highway fund
bonding you know and the other fund
bonding it's in there and it is bonded
but we don't manage to that number there
is in fact the same 10% cap on the
highway fund bonding but it usually it
works out all right without actually
being looked
at in in in layman's term with
everything you just said in layman's
term is we would look at the treasurer's
gold of of what number she gave us no
matter how the pay for of that is taken
care of well because you you would you
what we're saying is the other funds and
the highway funds going to pay a portion
of what we totally Bond yes but we only
consider the the treasur is giving you
the general fund bonding
Target only the general fund Target so
then that's why I'm trying to ask these
questions so we can clarifying so you
would take the general let's say hyp
hypthetically they said 100 uh 120
million okay good number then we could
say uh on top of that 120 million we're
going to add uh 4.6 million and then uh
22 million on top of the 120 million so
the general fund is expected to pay $120
million Bond and then others would add
would let's go back to your buckets
let's go back to your buckets you got
well that still goes to 143 million yeah
it doesn't matter this this committee is
charged with bucket a that's that's the
treasur side B Highway funds we have no
say
on Buck so the rest of the buckets will
all add up to your 200 but our purview
is bucket a is it going to be 120 or
143 represent Bogart it might be helpful
if you were to look at the house bill
five that your Bond's
authorized what page was that or page
five it's uh starts on line eight
and if you y you drop to line 11
exceeding the sum of 170 million and
then you go to line 13 the general fund
amount is 143 the highway fund amount is
4.6 and the other funds is 22
okay so the the bill when the body um
adopts it would give the the treasurer
the ability to bond up to $170
million and the source of funds for that
$70 million would be um found on lines
13 and
14 that's what I was trying to get to
well I'm glad I could help you thank you
and what the rating agencies look at is
debt as a percentage of unrestricted
revenue and when they say that they mean
general fund bonded debt as a percentage
of general fund unrestricted
Revenue which hypothetically and in fact
and which they'd like to have under 10%
and in fact they like to have the in
fact it's a statutory requirement that
the highway fund be under 10% also but
that usually just works out so we don't
actually manage to that number
representative representative Jack I
would I would recommend that uh we
adjourn this meeting and handle any
other question commit handle all the No
No handle any remaining questions just
take them offline to Mr Shay sounds like
an EXC mean time there's no reason to
keep sounds like an excellent plan we
done
e